los motivos esgrimidos por el gobierno
francés son básicamente la complicada
situación de orden público que se vive
en todo el país por la Reforma pensional
en un comunicado la presidencia francesa
aseguró hoy que ante el anuncio de una
nueva jornada de protestas para el
martes 28 de marzo se ha decidido
postergar Esta visita de estado que era
la primera del Rey Carlos tercero al
exterior desde que ascendió al Trono Y
que además de incluir París viviría a
bordo y tendría un banquete de estado en
esta comunicación El palacio del Eliseo
asegura que esta decisión fue tomada por
los gobiernos francés y británico tras
un intercambio telefónico entre el
presidente macron y el Rey Carlos III
esta mañana para poder darle la
bienvenida a Su Majestad el Rey Carlos
III en las condiciones que corresponden
a nuestra relación de amistad y es
cierto que la elección de Francia como
el primer destino internacional del Rey
Carlos tercero era bien significativo
por esa nueva relación de amistad que
están teniendo el Reino Unido y Francia
el Palacio de boquina ha dicho que sus
majestades el Rey Carlos y la reina
Camila esperan con ansias la oportunidad
de poder Francia Tan pronto sus agendas
lo permitan Esta visita del Rey Carlos
está gira antes de la coronación el 6 de
mayo incluía también Alemania y esta
parte del viaje si continuará así lo
anunciado el Palacio de boquina